so but we've had her before and she's
both a painter and a pianist
and i know she's told me this before but
i still need to
figure out she speaks four languages but
i need to figure out what those four
languages are
please everyone welcome sonia to the
stage
my name is sonia ang good morning and my
topic today will be
about responsible ai ethics and beyond a
principled approach from microsoft
um there'll be a couple of topics that
i'll be touching and
i'll start with talking about
how ai can help humanity today what are
those issues that we face
and then i'll be introducing microsoft's
ai ethics framework and then how are we
going to be putting that framework into
action
so
let's begin by
letting me introduce those challenges
that ai has brought to humanity and some
of those issues behind it
um
over the past
five years or even more you have seen
that has greatly changed our lives and
we have all witnessed this personally
let's take a look at some of these
examples of how microsoft has actually
brought change to society in using and
implementing ai and how its impact has
been felt from a socio-economic or
social technological point of view
so
microsoft has been championing
a global project called ai for good
it's our 125 million commitment to
empower those working around the world
to solve humanitarian issues and advance
global sustainability
and of course amplify human capability
this initiative is actually made up of
several programs the first is ai for
earth
so this program focuses on agriculture
biodiversity
climate change and of course protect
these endangered species
all these endangered species from
extinction
and then there is ai for accessibility
this would help
everyone or help people especially with
disabilities in their daily life
we have ai for humanitarian action
which helps these non-profit and
humanitarian organizations with disaster
response
refugees who are displaced and that's
very relevant today
human rights and of course the needs of
children
ai for cultural heritage
to preserve and enrich the cultural
heritage that we have those landmarks
important landmarks around the world and
lastly we have ai for health
ai for health allows you to help people
combat disease and that's so relevant
today and of course
remain healthy
now
aside from that
we have seen ai
through the past five years also
experienced this amazing breakthrough
in technology and research
microsoft has led the industry in
creating these amazing breakthroughs so
for example in 2016
object recognition and image recognition
has achieved human parity
speech recognition in 2017 has reached
human parity
reading comprehension speech synthesis
and so on and fast forward to 2020 we
now see ai systems be able to compose
songs
be able to paint paintings
compose literature and so on because of
a technology called openai gpt3
amazing isn't it
so
um
if you think about it
we've spent the last 30 years teaching
people how to use computers
and now we are teaching
computers how to understand the world
so the question really will be
well will that change be good or bad
we need to
to really put a thoughtful approach to
ensure
we create a future that we want to see
and not that we want to fear
but along with all these innovation
right
comes a responsibility to make sure that
our future is secured
and that means taking care
through collective stewardship of
research and innovation
that is present
case in point now
we were reminded of this responsibility
in 2016 when we released a chat bot
maybe people have remembered this very
well a chat bot called tay on twitter
so
we thought tay to learn things that were
unsupervised
from interactions with twitter users so
she could actually better replicate
human communication and personality
traits
however within 24 hours users realized
that she could learn and began to feed
her bigoted rhetoric
turning her from a very polite bot to a
vehicle of speech i mean hate speech
so this experience taught us that while
technology may not be unethical on its
own
people do not always have good
intentions so we must consider this
um
this human element when designing ai
systems
and we have learned to prepare for these
new types of attacks that influence
learning data sets especially ai systems
that have automatic learning
capabilities
so
what has
i mean why is ethical data
collection
why does this matter
so how was the data collected one was
one should be thinking about that
in what way was it collected
what kind of data was it trained on what
is the impact now of that data to the
final application and as you could see
here these examples show you how
it has impacted for example a system
where in it can't really distinguish
very much
or recognize an individual if he was not
a white guy or for example an mit
student couldn't graduate
from her thesis because the system would
refuse to actually you know blend in
with the parameters that she has for
facial recognition
so these are kind of things that we need
to to really think about
moreover there's the aspect of
human bias
and i don't know if you've heard about
this
about survivorship bias or it's a form
of selection bias but
uh
this picture is worth a thousand words
so this happened actually in world war
ii
when those airplanes were all bullet
riddled and so the question was when it
came back to the shop is where do we
reinforce this airplane should we
reinforce it at those spots where you
know typically that's what we all think
less reinforces where all these bullet
holes are
but lo and behold that's really not
where it is
actually a statistician
that and said you should reinforce that
airplane where the propellers are and
where the nose is
and you will actually increase the
survivor
survivorship of
the pilot
and that makes a lot of sense actually
and this bias is also pro
propagated in many of the things that we
see for example like this the search for
you know all top ceos and we all see
nothing but males for example
that said
we saw from a survey that 9 out of 10
organizations across different countries
have really encountered ethical issues
resulting from the use of ai
and that's really high
with that in mind
as useful as ai is
we at microsoft think that we must be
realistic about the challenges that ai
will also raise
indeed we we don't really believe that
we can afford to look at this
um
ai future that we have with uncritical
eyes so
this is why microsoft has spent a lot of
time thinking about how to deliver ai in
a way that is responsible and realizes
the potential in a way that also
addresses its challenges so let's take a
closer look at
ethics and the microsoft framework
of responsible ai
what are the tenants of this
so
microsoft believes that the development
and the deployment of ai must be guided
by the creation of an ethical framework
and there should be these four core
principles of fairness reliability
safety
privacy and security and inclusiveness
these are underpinned by two
foundational principles of transparency
and accountability so let's go one by
one in each of these so with fairness we
need to ensure that the ai system is
fair and not programmed to make biases
or discriminatory decisions
ai systems should treat everyone fairly
and avoid affecting similarly situated
groups of people
in different ways
an example of these here that you could
see
are
that the system may behave unfairly and
cause harm to others
especially when it tries to provide
guidance on medical treatment
loan applications or even employment
it should make the same recommendations
to everyone
with similar backgrounds so to help
mitigate bias
one should really
use training data sets
that reflect the diversity of society
one should also design ai models in a
way that allows them to learn and adapt
over time without developing such biases
so there are three types of unfairness
here that are being shown quality of
service harm of allocation and
stereotyping
let's go to the next
reliability and safety
so to build trust it's critical that ai
systems operate reliably safely and
consistently
under normal circumstances and in
unexpected conditions
this system should be able to operate as
though they were as they were actually
originally designed and responds safely
to un this unanticipated
conditions so that it could resist
harmful manipulation
it's also important to be able to verify
that these systems must behave as
intended under actual operating
conditions
so let's take a look at some of these
examples
well first of all we believe that
rigorous testing is essential during
system development
and deployment
so that we could ensure that ai systems
can respond safely in unanticipated
situations and edge cases
such that it would not have these
unexpected performance failures case in
point was a
story in the news before about this
robot
who actually mistook
its owner's hair as dirt and so while
the owner was sleeping it went and
sucked in all the hair of this woman
and it took 30 minutes for the paramedic
she called 9-1-1
and
actually took 30 minutes for a paramedic
when they reached the house to
disentangle her from the robot
so that's really a very unusual story
but yes we would be needing something
like error analysis tools and rigorous
testing that would help provide a
process for automated error analysis to
discover those regions in the model or
the machine learning model where
lower accuracy or performance is
occurring
another thing is
privacy privacy and security
so
with ai
privacy and data security issues require
especially close attention because
access to data is essential for ai
systems to make very accurate and
informed predictions and decisions about
people
so ai systems must really comply with
privacy laws and require transparency
about the collection use and storage of
data that mandate that consumers have
appropriate control
over how to use or choose the data that
is used
case in point
here
would be the um
the story of
actually
strava i don't know if you've known if
you know about this company called
strava
so
strava sells physical fitness equipment
and
when they sell it to different groups of
people and they sold it a lot to the
military because people in the military
do a lot of exercise
and then one day they decided to publish
via satellite oh here's how people have
adopted our
our gadget
and by doing that
they actually exposed soldiers to real
danger because it exposed areas like
this in the map
which are our military bases in hidden
areas in afghanistan in niger in south
africa and so on around the world
and that was a news actually in 2018.
so this is
an extreme case in point where really
privacy and security should really be
protected
let's go to the next
which is inclusiveness
at microsoft
we believe that everyone
should benefit from intelligent
technology meaning to say that it must
incorporate
and address a broad range of human needs
and experiences
so for one billion people around the
world who have disabilities
this is actually a game changer
so ai can improve access to education
government services employment
and a wide range of other opportunities
so
with the aging global population there
is a rise today of non-communicable
disease
global pandemics and more than 2 billion
people at least need assistive products
by 2030.
so our you know our solutions or our
systems our ai systems that provide
speech to text transcription
visual recognition predictive text
functionalities are already there
empowering those who have hearing
and visual and other types of
impairments
and it's not about
just people with disabilities
for example just acknowledging diversity
and inclusion of people who are just
trying to fill out an ordinary form
are they appropriately classified are
they appropriately identified here right
and not just say h above 30
when they fill out the form
right
so
oops sorry about that but uh i got
delayed here in my
my slide so anyway let's talk about the
next which is transparency so underneath
with
underlying transparency we have two
fundamental
principles that are involved when ai
systems are used to help
inform decisions
then there is a tremendous impact on
people's lives it is critical then that
people understand those decisions that
were made
for example
if you look at the bank today and how
they make decisions
with people who are credit worthy how is
it really done what did the system
really do here right you want to
understand how that system made that
decision so a crucial part of
transparency is
what we call intelligibility or useful
explanation of the behavior
the system or the algorithm should be
able to understand or explain
why and how it functioned that way
and let's take a look at some of these
examples
or how we are able to
promote transparency
so
with transparency notes on all our
systems right this uh this is able to
explain in simple terms how technology
works the intended use cases of it and
what to avoid and the key factors that
impact performance
also we have something called
responsible deployment guides that
contain recommendations
and develop
customers
develop
guides to responsible computing
more or less what happens here is that
with our models in azure machine
learning for example we have totally
we have what we call explainable models
so we use a variety of techniques here
like shop
and others that we ins in fact microsoft
is the one who has invented some of
these explainable explainability models
like ebm
was invented by microsoft to explain
models machine learning models
so last but not least is accountability
so
with organizations um
today in the world
they have to look at some of these
industry standards to develop
accountability norms and these norms can
ensure that ai systems are not the final
authority or
this is not going to be the ultimate
decision that would impact i mean that
the person would use to impact his or
her life
humans have to have control
over those systems that
are highly autonomous
a case in point here is the driverless
car
so
when a car hits a person who gets to be
blamed
who do i sue when i get hit by this
would it be the manufacturer would it be
the software vendor or would it would it
be the driver
that's really interesting and that's
being debated right now and actually a
lot of norms have been are being
established around this today
and aside from that
things like
um sensitive use cases right
so these sensitive use cases are what
is important to be able to understand
accountability so we looked at some of
these earlier which is
like the denial of services
right
causing injury and harm
and of course the infringement of human
rights
that said
how do we now put these into practice
what this what did microsoft do
in order for us to be able to
put all of these
into actual practical sense
so let's take a look at
these examples
well
we put responsible ai and our principles
into practice through a development of
resources and systems of governance
some of our guidelines our practices
include human ai
and conversational ai guidelines
inclusive design guidelines and an ai
fairness checklist
we also established
a governance office wherein we have a
ethics committee it's called the
responsible ai ethics committee that's
run by an officer
and of course an ai handbook
that contains all these governance and
principles
with that said
we also have established and as i
mentioned earlier several types of tools
that are that are ready to help you
govern
um and put ai ethics into practice these
tools can be like
as i mentioned earlier the
interpretability tools interpret ml
homomorphic encryption
data drift when you see that the model
is drifting through time and checking
the data for its accuracy
so all of these are things that i think
must be done by
organizations in order to implement
ai ethics so at the highest level we've
launched all of these series of research
papers that set the context behind ai
systems and to further collaborate we
also have this open source we open
source many of these tools and data sets
so that others can contribute and build
to this
so as a parting
oh as a conclusion
i would like to
just quote our
chief legal officer brad smith
when he said in his book
that
the more powerful the tool the greater
the benefit or the damage it can cause
technology innovation is not going to
slow down
but
the work to manage it needs to speed up
so with that said i am concluding my
presentation i hope you um enjoyed it
thank you
thank you very much
before we turn to the break we have some
book giveaways